ladies and gentlemen uh we're in the
home stretch of the conference uh The
Best Is Yet To Come no no offense to any
of my other
speakers but uh I've really been excited
about this conference uh in so many ways
uh because of the quality of our
speakers the quality of the information
but especially the quality of this book
The Post American
presidency and who we have to listen to
now the author Pamela Geller I met uh
several years ago at a conference in New
York sponsored by the Hudson
Institute uh many years ago uh looking
at the problem s of the UN and of course
America survival my group has been
focused on the UN problem since we
founded the group uh about 12 years
ago
and since then uh she was always writing
a great blog ATL shrugs but has really
taken off in the public eye uh in so
many
ways clearly a successful blogger
who's amazingly prolific you've got to
read it uh to believe it a new material
every day I mean I can't do that and I
think I write pretty much a lot uh try
to write a couple thousand words every
every day or so but she's always up
there with the latest
information but in addition to providing
news and
information uh being an activist
and became even more in the public eye
with her campaign against the ground
zero mosque she has also in addition to
her blogging uh founded the
group stop islamization of
America this book though and I'm glad we
have the copies here to provide to you
and I know Pam was going to stay after
to sign the
books is really the best one out on the
Market about Obama and I've read them
all and there are many good books out
there but when you read this book you
will immediately understand her style
and I you'll hear it you'll see it in
person in a
second it goes right to the heart of the
issue doesn't beat around the bush
doesn't make excuses for the president
look at the subtitle the Obama
administration's War on
America and of course when I was
considering doing this conference on Al
jazer I
thought we need somebody like Pamela
Geller who's very critical and opposed
to the islamization of America and who
will recognize and does recognize that
Al jazer is a big part of
it so many people seem to think we can
fight this Threat by ignoring the
propaganda Channel and the war of the
airwaves the war of news and information
and we can't especially when Al jazer is
inside the United States and pushing at
this particular moment ladies and
gentlemen for Carriage not only on the
public TV stations we heard about
earlier but on the big cable and
satellite systems especially
Comcast if you go to our website usas
survival. org you will be able to get
all of the documents that we've been
provided we' provided to you today uh
except for the
book and that includes a letter to
Comcast CEO Brian Roberts warning him
about what happens if he goes ahead
under pressure from Al jazer and its
media lackies in expanding distribution
of this channel in the United States I'm
so happy that Pamela has joined us today
and is a part of this effort let me give
you a little bit more about her work
because she is so prolific I mean in
preparation for this conference she was
not only posting on her blogs I saw a
piece on The Daily Caller and but she
also writes for Andrew breitbart's
websites big government big journalism
and all the rest her role as an activist
in making a difference getting National
publicity on such shows as 60 Minutes in
opposition to the Ground Zero mosque
have earned her the Annie Taylor award
en courage presented by the David
Horowitz Freedom Center and she's broken
some amazing Stories on her blog about
foreign funding of the Obama campaign
coming from guess where uh and also I
was interested to find out last night
when we were having dinner that she's
the first blogger who actually
posted an analysis a critical analysis
of the president a birth
certificate uh it's not a birth
certificate it's a certification of
birth of live birth whatever is the name
they put up there for it and and I know
that runs the risk for uh our friends
from Media Matters and other such groups
and labeling uh Pamela
uh and others as birthers but let me
tell you there's nothing wrong with
questioning official documents from the
president of the United States when they
are not so official under scrutiny one
of the things I did later
on uh was dig up a copy of my own birth
certificate and I put it online through
accuracy and media and I compared it to
the president's certification of live
birth and lo and behold my birth
certificate I actually had information
on there about my doctor the doctor who
delivered me uh my name of my
Hospital uh even had my father's
occupation uh working as he did for many
many years at Owens corny
fiberglass and uh you compare that to
the president's birth certificate or
certification of live birth and you find
the president's uh
uh document uh doesn't have a lot of
that information does it no
hospital uh no attending
physician so questions about that are
and continue to be legitimate as even
Donald Trump has been talking about so
Pamela raises those issues she comes
under attack for it they're after her
big time and she's here to talk to us
today Pamela
[Applause]
thank you Cliff thank you all for
attending
um we are at
War uh I the gravity of which is
difficult to convey because there's an
overt war and there is a covert
War uh clearly the violent Jihad very
easy
uh weekly we're seeing you know attacks
that are thwarted a couple weeks ago
weapons of mass destruction in Texas
last night Camp Pendleton there was an
attempt to break security um a myriad
attacks Time
Square the Ford hood Jihadi uh that's
easy that's easy but there is a stealth
Jihad there's an academic Jihad as very
well articulated by Lee Kaplan an
economic Jihad not just in the obvious
ways uh that um the economic specialist
uh uh explained but also in the
financing of sharia Finance where
they're using taxpayer dollars um to
advance Sharia finance a week after the
Obama Administration uh nationalized
some banks the US Treasury Department
was giving seminars for example in
Sharia Finance
people say as what's the big deal well
the big deal is I don't want my taxpayer
dollars being used to finance a a
Islamic funding which has to be Halal
that means 10% has to go to zakat which
funds Jihad it has to there's a
Prohibition on pork there's a
Prohibition on Tobacco there's a pro
prohibition on certain uh forms of
entertainment I don't want my tax pay
dollars going to bankrupt whole American
sectors but the most powerful
and Lethal Weapon in this war now is the
information war in the war of ideas the
war is in the information battle space
and Al jazer is the most potent
weapon it is Unthinkable that this
Outlet could be making its way into the
United States and while the left in
media may say it's not a big deal or you
see the big names that go to their their
dinners what are you saying that you're
not taking
sides well I mean I just want to
understand what are you saying that
there is a movement a global movement
not a conspiracy theory a conspiracy
fact the global Jihad there's conspiracy
theory and conspiracy fact that is vowed
to destroy our
civilization and you're not taking sides
that's taking a
side that's taking a side against us
it's interesting to me that Islamic
propaganda
mouthpieces like Al jaer are lorded
revered
respected and anyone on the other side
that speaks candidly and frankly about
Islamic
Jihad is marginally
destroyed this is by the way the Sharia
does the media know that they're
enforcing the Sharia are they
consciously doing it you know what I
don't care I don't care what motive is I
care about action people say you think
Muhammad's a
Muslim no I I don't care my question is
if he was or he wasn't what would he be
doing differently this is what I care
about so the
media is enforcing blasphemy
laws blasphemy in Islam is you cannot
defame Islam you cannot slander Islam
even if it's true look at har Builders a
friend and colleague of mine in in in
Holland uh third in line um third third
largest party in in Holland made a small
film 15-minute film called
fitner basically showing the terrorist
attacks and the Hadith that inspired
them or Sur and he's on trial for hate
speech and the Dutch Criminal Court said
it doesn't matter if you're telling the
truth what matters is it's against the
law that's
Sharia and so the Western media when
they won't run the Danish cartoons they
wouldn't run them now you saw them they
were fairly innocuous cartoons so what
that's self- enforcing Sharia here uh uh
there was the uh South Park producers
were threatened with death because they
actually dared say the word Muhammad
which by the way Comedy Central bleeped
out and they put Muhammad in a Huggy
Bear costume because you can't show
Muhammad so they were threatened with
death so some innocuous uh and unknown
cartoonist in Seattle said well let's
everybody draw Muhammad day like they
can't kill us all she had no idea what
she was walking into she recanted in 24
hours didn't
matter now did didn't matter now was
there a f were placed on her head but
the FBI said she had to go into witness
protection her name is Molly nris how
many people in this audience know who
Molly naris
is wow I'm impressed usually I get no
hands she should be the poster girl for
free speech in America but again this
speaks to
the advance of Islamic supremacism this
is Islamic supremacism I had to sue
Detroit to get my buses up my freedom
buses up I was running buses in cities I
was covering the riab Barry trial I had
gone to Florida because the parents that
had threatened to kill her were trying
to get her back into the uh fatal
household and I was in Florida I saw
these buses prosti for Islam come to
Islam why Islam and I thought what about
these people that are trying to leave
Islam
what what do they do so I I created bus
ads I took the same exact artwork
leaving Islam it said is your family
threatening you come to Refuge from
islam.com well I it became a huge news
story this is a huge news
story this is it why this is how far
down the rabbit hole the West has gone
that this is a huge news story eight
buses in New York City 10 buses in Miami
and banned in
Detroit and only one newspaper actually
went and said is there a need for this
and went and spoke to people in the
Muslim Community the Washington Times
and one teacher in a Dearborn School
said Thank God somebody's doing this and
I was on Fox and you know these
anti-islam ads I said they're not
anti-islam that's what they're called
anti-islam anybody that opposes these
ads is supporting the death penalty for
apostasy for leaving Islam well why are
you encouraging people to leave Islam I
said I'm not it says leaving Islam
exclamation point not leaving
I mean a question mark not exclamation
point I'm not saying leave Islam I'm
saying leaving Islam do you need help
and believe me they do need help you
have no idea because it's not just the
uh let's say if you were an abused
spouse it's not just the the spouse it's
the family it's the mosque it's the
community depending upon the
devoutness so you really have to get to
a safe house that's really protected if
you if you if you're going to do this no
clue people have no clue those are you
going to tell me that apostates in
America do not have the same individual
rights as the Islamic supremacists that
would have them stay under the boot of
Islamic
supremacism that's not what our
constitution
says so yesterday I'm proud to report
that we won our lawsuit in
Detroit
yes and Those ads will run in Dearborn a
little bit about yeah my first campaign
was in April they were the very first I
I was turned
down uh the issue of uh the expansion of
Al jazer in the United States can only
be likened to the expansion expansion of
of
goal a minister of propaganda at the
time of World War II no organization has
done as much damage to spread hate and
lies and incitement as
aler Al jazer is the leading terrorist
propaganda organization in the world
Jihad Mastermind Anor alaki has praised
Al jazer and several years ago and I I
want to say something about Anor alaki
if I
may an oraki was the go-to Imam for the
New York Times And The Washington Post
and all the major Media news outlets
right after
911 at the same time he was the
spiritual guide and adviser to a number
of
911 um Muslim
terrorists this is a very important
point because you never saw the New York
Times ever say you know there's more at
work here than meet to the
eye you don't even have to say we were
taken but you could say we did not
understand the threat no no no no no
they just keep moving on like nothing
happened so here was an Imam who was the
leading media voice for Islam while
guiding not just the 9/11 Muslim
terrorists but the Ford hood
Jihadi now you know we've been
infiltrated when the Pentagon the dod
cannot in its investigation of the for
Hui bring themselves to speak to
religious
motivation here you have a terrorist who
was not only screaming Alo abbar that
morning who not only had on his business
card a story I broke s SOA soldier of
Allah who Not only was giving out qurans
the morning of his Jihad who was not
only wearing the bar the Shahed when he
mowed down our unarmed
soldiers anaki was his
Imam what is being done to address this
in the United States there have been
18,000 Islamic attacks since 911 each
one with the imperer of a Muslim cleric
what is being done except to attack
people like me for pointing this
out really why aren't the Islamic
supremacists attacking the extremists
why are we getting attacked why Robert
Spencer wafa suan ibben War why do we
get
attacked oh you're anti-muslim no I'm
counter Jihad I don't care if you
worship a stone just don't Stone me with
it that's it that's my that's my that's
my Line in the Sand okay let's talk
let's talk about aler it's very very
scary and you are the
soldiers you are the foot soldiers in
this war you you must understand this no
one is going to save you you have to
save yourself if it means contacting
Peter King's office first of all each
one of you is a small media organization
every single one of you you have email
lists you belong to groups maybe you
play Maran I don't
care each one is a tentacle to a larger
to a to a larger group and there's a
ripple effect look The Ground Zero
mosque was announced in December 2009
you did not hear anything about it until
June
2010 that was the first number one
national news story and international
news story that was made number one
without the media the media carried it
when they had no choice they could not
no longer ignore that story when close
to 6,000 people showed up at the first
rally and some 30,000 at the June at the
September 11th Rally or the media said
they were like, 1500 people
there we are I mean stop hand ringing
about the media it's over you are you
are Guerilla media organizations that's
what you are you have to get on your
list that everybody has to right to
King that Al jazer it should be
designated a terrorist
organization just like almanar almanar
is designated a terrorist organization
and it's prohibited from the United
States and please don't tell me about
free speech I am a free speech Advocate
This Is
War This Is War this is an incitement to
to to radicalize the American Muslim
population there's no question about it
that's the
objective um uh and and there's no
difference by the way between the AL
manob broadcast and the AL ales the ales
broadcasts there's not oh and by the way
they're now developing children's
programming it's devilish it's devilish
and we are not even raising a hand in
our own civilizational
defense this is in a word
civilizational
suicide that
we through centuries of blood and toil
and intellectual wrestling came to this
point in history where for the first
time in human history you had a
government a moral the first moral
government based on individual rights
yes that's what America was the first
Noble government moral government based
on individual rights first
time and everything Noble and just and
Brilliant and magnificent that this
country achieved was a logical Fidelity
to that very
principle and we throwing away with both
hands it's it's it's
Unthinkable as far as Obama I mean this
book just I I want to stay on aler I
really don't want to talk about the book
so much I spent years researching the
book
years uh because Obama was marketed to
the unit to the the the the American
public like uh Diet
Coke he was
delivered by the best Ad Agency in the
world the thing with the documents when
when the person wrote to me who was a
digital forensic examination specialist
back in May in June of 2008 and he said
to me that it's been altered and he was
uh really a real specialist I I I'm not
going to reveal who he is but I
investigated him I said and he would
testify in government trials I said well
you have to present to me like I'm I'm a
jury and all I did was run that the the
C was indeed altered I never said he was
born in France and I never said he you
know I that's all I said I said there's
something I miss now it's interesting to
me that every single document from every
other president was analyzed to the in
degree I mean here when they didn't find
what they wanted with bush they actually
took his medical record from his
national service okay I mean this is how
anal they were with
documents and yet we can't see a
passport in ' 81 when he went to
Pakistan when he was under martial
law who went to Pakistan anyway all
right we won't go there I mean in 81 it
was under martial law whatever okay we
don't see a school wreck we don't see a
student loan application we don't see a
transcript he was the president of
Harvard Law review my god there should
be reams of paperwork nobody asks the
question you would go into I would go
into urban outfit is where there are
trays of t-shirts you know in Manhattan
Betty Boop peanuts
Obama there was no McCain no I'm trying
to tell I'm trying to it was the cult of
celebrity the man was not vetted and let
me say this we depend on our media to
our candidates that's the function of a
free press and our press has advocated
its role as public servant and has
literally become a propaganda arm for
what I consider to be a very subversive
movement
so Al jazer is just the natural step
nothing is static nothing is standing
still everything is fluid and what's
going on right now is very very
frightening in the Middle East here we
had in June of 2009 a revolution in Iran
and look at the pictures I mean I
covered it extensively and many of the
twitterers like Persian kiwi uh that
were giving me the pictures and the
information have never been heard from
again
but the pictures that I had were
devastating I mean devastating first of
all was women with lipstick and eyeliner
some with he job some not so what and
zarrian and everybody was in the streets
if you notice these recent revolts it's
always men screaming
alakar he ignored it and it was horrible
the way they were first of all raping
men and women to death in the prisons to
scare the families killing them in the
street I mean they were hanging them in
the street
Obama didn't say a word so when I hear
him on Monday night talk about
humanitarian it is so it is so dishonest
I I don't agree with you that it's
incoherent I don't believe that there's
no motive here I'm sorry because again
by their fruits you shall know him and
so we know him he did nothing he did
nothing in Iran and let me tell you
something that was one of those once in
a century
opportunities because first of all you
can say well I don't want to go to war I
w't go to war under any circumstances I
won't go to war but he's gone to
Libya so if you're going to expend
American maybe blood obviously treasure
you have to do it in N your National
interest only we are guilty of wanting
to do something on no one well
everyone's allowed except us you have to
do things not in your
interest but everybody else is killing
people and Ste for their own National
interest so he ignored Iran now Iran is
the head of the
snake Iran is the head of the snake in
Iraq you know uh funding funding and
agitating in Iraq when we were there
under Bush and subsequently in Bahrain
you have a Sunni uh government a Shia
population they're making the trouble
there they were aligned with Muslim
Brotherhood in
Egypt I mean this is you will notice
that these revolts are in US Allied
Muslim
countries and while I may not love the
puppet that many times the United States
supports okay yeah he's our
puppet and the alternative is much worse
now I would like to live in a perfect
world with perfect people and perfect
outcomes there's no such thing what are
we doing in
Libya what are we doing in Libya I'm
asking you and then last night for the
Obama Administration to say listen uh we
told the rebels
uh you're not allowed to kill any
civilians no no no no side is allowed to
kill civilians I would first of all
who's a
civilian I am not advocating for killing
civilians This Is War what what do we
think this
is so I was deeply troubled by what
shaped him the early parts of my book of
course I do go into his background I
think it is seminal to understanding his
worldview yes I think it matters that
Not only was his father born a Muslim
his stepfather was a Muslim he was
raised in a Muslim country from the ages
of 6 to 12 he took quranic classes he
took Islam I think that's Germain to his
worldview and the reason why he's so
islamophilia he is who redirects the
national aeronautic space agency cuts
the Challenger Cuts uh space programs
and tells them to redirect their efforts
to the Muslim
world what so they could get sharpen
better blades they don't want sharp
blades they like to make the beheadings
very painful today eight people eight un
employees un employees this is important
are slaughtered in Afghanistan because
of the Quran the Quran was burned
somewhere they desecrate Bibles they not
they don't allow Bibles in Malaysia I
don't even have to go into this I'm a
free speech Advocate I don't like Quran
burning I don't believe in burning books
okay I I don't but who cares who died
and made the Quran the holy book that I
should care about the Quran oh the Quran
the Bible the oh why what
why this is what I'm saying about the
West the West made
oh don't do that you know you can put a
Jesus Christ in a glass of urine and say
it's odd this is this is odd wait a
minute it's
OD but they killed eight un employees
and behead two of them because a Quran
was burned and let me tell you something
they will blame uh the Quran burner I do
not blame the you couldn't get me to
behead somebody I don't care if you
burned my best Chanel Couture
yeah maybe maybe that's my religion I
want the same respect I want mutual
respect and mutual
reciprocity but I do equal rights
individual rights why is mine worth
less I speak for the smallest minority
in the world the individual period the
very idea that Al
jazer Shake kada is the
inspiration for this channel sh kadari
is the inspiration for the Muslim
Brotherhood the Muslim Brotherhood is
here in America the Muslim Brotherhood
as evidenced in the Holy Land trial the
largest terrorist funding trial in the
United States of America in our history
Muslim Brotherhood groups were named who
are these Muslim Brotherhood groups
every time you see a Muslim spokesman on
television it's the Muslim Brotherhood
whether it's the unindicted
co-conspirator Council of American
Islamic relations care the unindicted
co-conspirator Islamic Society of North
America isna nna the everything you see
and hear is filtered through the Muslim
Brotherhood and when someone has the
audacity to speak the truth in a Muslim
country you're assassinated in a western
country your character is
assassinated this is what they do they
destroy people but I won't be destroyed
and I'll tell you why and and the reason
why I bring this up is because I don't
want you to be afraid to
speak this is what they want they want
people to say oh I don't want any part
of that movement I don't want to be
labeled a racist islamophobic
anti-muslim
bigot that's how they shut people up you
must fight back when those passenger
Jets turned into missiles went into the
towers were those moms and dads and
doctors and lawyers and stock Brokers
and waiters were they wearing
uniforms were they our soldiers
they
are you are the
soldiers you have to make it happen
whether it's cluelessness or complicity
again I'm not interested in
motive it must be it must be it must be
addressed Al jazer on PBS no less I mean
you can't make this stuff up not only
they coming they're coming on you're
done this is how brilliant don't
underestimate this movement this is look
Islamic Jihad
is the only religious movement that has
a propaganda
arm and very very
effective a propaganda arm in the
religion it dictates it's it's the
language of
Lies everything that comes out of Al
jaer is a lie very distinctly unamerican
the Jew hatred is again kba K yay
mamed what is that I hear in the streets
of New York and anti Israel rallies you
hear it in Gaza you hear it in Europe
you heard it on the flotilla kba kba yay
mahamed
say so when they say it's and I'll tell
you what it means when they say it's
about
Israel a modern argument to an ageold
hate they say it's about land Again
comedy here is a country that's nine
miles at its wide no oil no o gold no
nothing just human resources and it's
about land surrounded by check this out
ginormous
Arab lands it's about this it's about
land it's not it's about Islamic
anti-Semitism which is part of the DNA
of Islam nobody talks about it I I have
at least a hundred quotes up on a page
called Islamic Jew hatred so you
understand when they're saying kba kba y
muhamed they're telling the Jews
remember
kba Kaiba is Medina Saudi Arabia that's
the Jews actually Saudi Arabia is is
occupied occupied territory it belongs
to the Jews I mean technically if you're
going to that's your that's your
premise anyway so Muhammad went into to
to to uh Medina and Saudi Arabia and he
and he eliminated the three tribes there
I mean one tribe that surrendered
because the other two were already
decimated they surrendered he still in
one night beheaded 800 men and the and
the and and the boys and took the women
as slaves Kar Kar kba y Jews don't the
armies of Muhammad are
coming where's the media on this you
hear of kba kba
yay go to YouTube Just put in kba kba
you'll see
hundreds all across the world Kaiba
Kaiba yayah it's Islamic anti-Semitism
where is the media on all this ethnic
cleansing of the Coptic Christians in in
in in Egypt in Indonesia in Malaysia I
mean what is being done to address the
the the third chapter of Islam which by
the way SU EDS the prior to it's abated
According to Islamic scholar scholarship
the latter part of the Quran supersedes
all that comes before it it's the most
violent what is being done just excuses
just excuses I'm the racist islamophobic
bigot I'm wrong and you're going to give
Al jazer Al jazer I mean I can't who was
it was it Ralph Peters yeah retired army
uh officer and Comm I'm sure you know
Ralph pet has called aler Killers with
cameras
Al jaer is so Al jaer is so consumed by
hatred of America and the West that the
network would rather see Iraq collapse
into blood bloodbath than permit the
emergence of a democracy
there I mean it's on and on the fact
that Ana oraki is a frequent guest and
noted religious scholar on Al jazer that
shik karwi who's the leader of the
Muslim Brotherhood has a weekly show and
don't think for one second that they're
not making clowns out of those students
that took to the streets because the you
know the Muslim Brotherhood was outlawed
in
Egypt and karwi returned a couple of
weekends a couple of weeks ago for
Friday pair millions in the streets and
the Google putts who orchestrated the
whole Revolt wasn't even allowed on
whale whale gonine was not even allowed
on the stage he was there to speak no
thank you very much you're done
so Al jazer what worries me about Al
jazer is to um
uh
propagandize uh the
Jihad uh VAV
America you may very well radicalize uh
American Muslims listen if you have a
chance uh the Christmas tree lighting
bomber the the uh was he 19 20y old
Muslim uh in Seattle want to bomb a
Christmas tree lighting uh and kill
25,000 people mostly families okay he
didn't get it off the fact that he
didn't get over was like well he didn't
get is that what has to happen the fact
that there's a plot and they're planning
and it's that's not the same as actually
killing the people since
when why do we have to die how many
people have to die I'm asking you we're
thating plots all the time what what
what has to
happen it it Grieves me that Obama I
think is very naked in whose side he's
on we he is relinquishing American
sovereignty to a an a worldwide
organization the United Nations which is
largely driven by the organization of
Islamic conference the OIC the OIC is a
collection a body of 56 Nations they say
57 because they already assume that
Israel's history and it's going to be
Palestine 57 countries okay that because
they vote as one block never in its
entire history has any one Muslim Nation
ever voted off The Block ever they vote
as one block which is why you see every
resolution against Israel not they
against the Jihad that was in darf War
how many millions were slaughtered under
that Jihad how
many you never hear about the Congo you
never you know it's so Israel is the
problem okay they're driving the bus all
of these
resolutions um against Free Speech this
is all blasphemy laws for the first time
in American history you had a US
president co-sponsor a resolution at the
UN to restrict Free
Speech this this is a very dangerous
time you must get
activated because no action is an action
and I will tell you that your children
will not grow up in any world that you
will recognize we are entering a very
dark age and you will not like what
comes after
America I don't know how are we for time
we ar for time do okay okay I can go on
yeah I'm like scary you know what I mean
um military analyst um James dunan uh
assigns Al jazer a primary role in the
rise of religious hatred and terrorism
in the modern Muslim
World um and Arab scholar Mahmud fondi
calls Al jazer the Muslim Brotherhood
Channel he explained that alzer is
already propag propagandizing for the
organization they loved Egypt did you
see them anywhere ing
Iran if you want to see Iran I have
about 160 posts devoted just to Iran the
revolution some of the pictures will are
very very graphic I'm sorry you have to
see it enough with this nonsense I have
to tell you that when Israel released
the family photos of the fogal
family um I had had arguments with them
they you know it's it's it's sacate you
can't do that you can't uh you know it
has to be respect for the dead so
whenever there was a terrorist attack
the cleanup I mean it was 10 minut it
was like unbelievable and it's like it
doesn't exist meanwhile over there in
Gaza they'll take a kid and trot him
around to different places and take
different pictures and pose him and this
and that and you don't even know how the
kid died you know but of course the Jews
did it but this is what I'm trying to
say I mean it is a propaganda War it's a
propaganda war and when I went to cover
the war in the summer of 2006 in Israel
you know I was it happened to be in the
same building is uh some of the people
from the Bush Administration and Karen
use could not leave a television set CNN
International in Al jaer oh my god look
what they're doing no you look what they
leave the hotel and go look at what
they're doing it was
unbelievable but if you lose the
propaganda War you lose the war because
all the bullets and the bombs and the
Bloodshed come as a result of what
happens in this
war and we are not even putting up a
fight we're just not I mean everybody
the law the big complaint is Fox News I
got to tell you I find Fox left of
Senter you can chuckle chuckle away in
the back I do but that's you see again
you it's your perspective every other
channel is so
left so one perspective the fact that
fox gives both sides makes them very far
right I would love to see on the on the
right an MSNBC a CNN an ABC and ABC and
NBC I'd like to see that on on the right
you don't but you're welcome in Al jazer
and people that speak out are are you
know IM immediate immediately ridiculed
marginalized you have to get used to
that by the way it had if if you're you
know it's the military uh the old
military axom that if you're catching
Flack then you're over your target so
every time I catch black I do a little
dance the bigger and uglier the name the
prouder I
am because that the fight is very ugly
and you are right and you are righteous
and that's where you're going to get
your suor and the fact that truth is the
recognition of
reality and that you are going to fight
for that
reality we have assumed our freedom for
too long this is this is even I before
911 I mean you know I was the associate
publisher of the New York Observer I had
you know the fashion channel on all the
time I mean I just yeah Metro you know
full fontal fashion um I just assumed my
freedom I loved my life I loved it I was
completely and utterly free I never
questioned my oh women's rights I you
know and those Fe you know don't even
talk to me about the feminism because
I'm a male chauvinist Pig um well it's
rooted in Len Lenin uh you know Marxist
Dogma um but again what I'm saying is
that you cannot assume your freedom
because no matter how modern we become
uh the human human nature never changes
and good and evil are always present and
you're not allowed to say that there's
no good and there's no evil this is
another problem that we have the
inability to between right and wrong so
nobody's right nobody's wrong wrong
there is a right and there is a wrong
there is a good and there is an evil and
you better be able to distinguish
between the
two on that note right I'm
done all right ladies and gentlemen
we're going to end it there and set
Pamela up with uh an autograph signing
for her books so you can take your books
right out can we get that set up and U
and you can talk to her while you get
your books signed and
and well we're running out of time is
the problem and but I want to make sure
everybody gets their books signed
because I I mean this is a great note
frankly to end on an inspiring talk from
somebody who's forceful who's in the
front lines and who has believe you me
been taking a lot of
attacks there's some things you can do
quickly to help us America survival we
need your
support call write Congressman Peter
King support him ask him to go further
there's much more that can be done don't
criticize necessarily offer constructive
criticism that we need to get busy we
need to act more quickly alera should be
under the microscope before it does too
much more damage and inspires more
homegrown cases of jihadism and more
American lives are lost thank you so
much for coming we appreciate it
[Applause]
she